[Musique]
avec vous là une frappe bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline à la une de la
presse aujourd'hui la poursuite du
mouvement de contestation en Iran où le
guide suprême layatollah Ali ramenaia a
réagi pour la première fois à ce qu'il
qualifie je cite des meute mais comme à
son habitude le dirigeant iranien accuse
les ennemis juridiques il sera elle et
les États-Unis d'avoir fomenté la
révolte des accusations du Mans relayées
évidemment par la presse officielle que
je vais vous montrer immédiatement à
commencer par le herendelli qui montre
on le voit le guide à lire ramener lors
d'une intervention une cérémonie
militaire pardon hier à Téhéran une
démonstration de force de la part d'un
pouvoir on le sait qui est de plus en
plus violent vis-à-vis de la
contestation comme en témoigne les
images diffusées depuis dimanche de la
répression qui s'est abattue sur
l'université Sharif de Téhéran les
étudiants étaient pourcha visée par des
tirs embarqués par la police
les jeunes on le voit sont aux
avant-postes de la contestation mais
selon la sociologue Azad qui Anne ce
mouvement de révolte est en train de
s'étendre à d'autres groupes sociaux et
à d'autres parties du pays notamment au
sud les femmes continuant d'occuper une
place centrale dans la contestation les
Iraniennes auxquelles les dessinateurs
de presse du monde entier rendent
hommage avec ce premier dessin il est
signé du Marocain Imad sanoni où l'on
voit les cheveux d'une iranienne qui se
transforme en marteau et qui détruit la
statue du guide Ali Hamdi le guide
suprême qu'on retrouve dans ce dessin du
genre Dania Mourad cotcott représenté en
bouteilles qui enferme les femmes et
iraniennes et leurs droits les
Iraniennes enfermés
également dans ce dessin de Banegas on
les voit enfermés donc dans ce chat d'or
qui représente une prison un bras en
sort et il tient la Flamme de la Liberté
contestation également Hélène mais
beaucoup plus feutrée le contexte est
différent au Royaume-Uni houstien
actuellement le congrès annuel des
conservateurs en pleine fronde contre la
première ministre listrus et surtout
vous nous en parler ailleurs vous nous
en parler hier contre son ministre des
Finances et à peine à moi après son
élection la chef du gouvernement et son
chancelier de l'Échiquier quoi s'y
carteng affronte un vent de révolte tel
qu'ils ont déjà dû revenir sur une
mesure phare de leur programme la
suppression de la plus haute tranche
d'impôts qui auraient favorisé les plus
riches une volte-face qui ne suffit pas
néanmoins à rassurer leur camarades
d'après le gardien qui rapporte les
touristes sont maintenant déterminés à
obliger quarteng et Trust a renoncé à
leur projet de réduire et bien cette
fois les prestations sociales
leur virage sur les impôts provoquent
évidemment les moqueries de leur
détracteurs comme en témoignent cette
une du Daily Star qui les montre à bord
de la voiture rouge et jaune de Oui-Oui
on l'appelle nozi en anglais
scridge bruit de pneus freinant
brutalement en légende de lady is for
you turning le tableau it c'est ici une
déclaration de feu Maria Thatcher la
dame de fer qui se faisait une fierté de
ne jamais plier face à l'adversité et
dont l'histoire on le sait à promis
qu'elle serait la dignité les
dessinateurs de pressent évidemment n'en
loupe pas une miette scritch fait
toujours quoi ces cartaigne dans le
dessin de crescend Adams pour le Evening
Standard voici karting et listrus qu'on
retrouve dans le dessin de Motten Morlan
pour The Times dans cette fois ils ont
loupé leur virage et la première
ministre se trouve d'ailleurs déjà dans
un cercueil le dessinateur Martin
rossson pour The Garden ne crois pas au
mea culpa des deux dirigeants monsieur
humilité et Mademoiselle contrition à
Lyon à la déclaration qui a fait hier
quoi s’écartaigne qui a assuré que leur
volte-face était je le cite fait avec
humilité et contrition alors qu'ils sont
déjà tous les deux en train de préparer
déguiser les couteaux pour la suite que
ferait-on sans les dessinateurs
britanniques Hélène quelle suite à ce
propos donner en France là pour le coup
on renvoie du ministre de la Justice
Eric dupour-moretti devant la Cour de
Justice de la République pour prise
élégale d'intérêt une première pour un
ministre en exercice le débat agite la
presse française le ministre de la
Justice doit-il quitter le gouvernement
Eric Dupond-Moretti estime que non et
Libération cessait au jeu de mots le
ministre est prévenu pas tout à fait
encore puisque les avocats des règles
Dupont-Moretti ont formé un pourvoi en
cassation qui est donc suspensive
journal évoque une situation inédite
puisque jamais en effet un ministre la
justice n'avait fait l'objet d'un renvoi
devant la CGR inédite voire intenable
d'après l'humanité qui exige la
démission immédiate d'Éric
Dupond-Moretti une demande qui est aussi
formulée par Mediapart qui revient
également sur la mise en examen du
secrétaire général de l'Élysée Alexis
color pour prise illégale d'intérêt
trafic d’influence un lundi noir pour la
République exemplaire vantée par le
candidat Emmanuel Macron selon Mediapart
coup dur pour Emmanuel Macron et journée
noire pour
l'exemplarité en politique c'est ce qui
écrit également ce matin le quotidien de
belge Le Soir on ne se quitte pas
là-dessus Hélène et puisqu'on parle
d'Emmanuel Macron Pauline dans un
registre plus léger néanmoins le
Huffington Post annonce le lancement
hier par le président du site internet
du fameux Conseil national pour la
refondation via une vidéo de 13 minutes
tout le chef de l'État portait Pauline
un col roulé gris anthracite ce que nous
évidemment pas manqué de relever les
internautes et même la presse qui voit
dans ce changement de look une façon là
encore de sensibiliser les Français à la
crise énergique rappelons que la
tendance a été lancée en France par le
ministre des finances et de l'économie
Bruno Le Maire alors Pauline à quand le
col roulé bah écoutez j'adore rêve vu le
froid qu'il règne dans la rédaction de
France 24 merci beaucoup Hélène
malheureusement avec les micros c'est un
peu compliqué à tout